dans l'île de ré ma paire la flore et on
l'appelle ré la blanche blanche comme
ces maisons traditionnelles
si l'obtention de permis de construire
est déjà très réglementée
les problèmes de sur organisation se
pose quand même alors les maires de
l'île souhaiterait réduire le nombre de
nouvelles habitations
il était temps on fait d'arrêter
urbanisme et moi dans sa construction de
logements et de construction tout
simplement parce que le site ne le
permet plus ne permettra plus dans
l'avenir s'est gardé en fait le cas chez
l'homme de l'île de ré selon les maires
ce sont 55 hectares qui pourrait devenir
inconstructibles l'île longue d'une
trentaine de kilomètres est déjà bâtie
sur 20 % de sa surface
nous craignons quand même que ça puisse
être un jour remis en question comme du
reste le premier schéma directeur a été
remis en question puisque il était prévu
être saturé pour 2015
or l'an 2015 or déjà l'année dernière il
n'y restait dans certaines communes plus
qu'une maison à construire sur l'île qui
vit principalement du tourisme on risque
fort de connaître une véritable flambée
des prix des terrains constructibles des
terrains qui se vendent déjà aux
environs de 1000 francs le mètre carré
ont réduit le champ des activités non
seulement le nom mais également celui
des artisans et commerçants de l'île de
ré au pas oublier l'île de ré vie
beaucoup de du bâtiment est en période
de divers c'est une activité qui est
très forte depuis 1988
rey doit assumer une véritable mutation
liés à la construction du pont les
routes sont saturés les routes resteront
telles qu'elles sont on va aménager
quelques carrefours parce que ça pose
quelques problèmes dans certains
endroits mais les routes resteront
telles qu'elles sont c'est clair en
protégeant l'île de ré les maires
souhaitent préserver une manne
touristique elle aussi unique